This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证是真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个节目聚焦于黑人男性的生活经历，进行坦诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方都可能不够安全，但你现在是在和一个知道自己在做什么的执照专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人一直背负着一副铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须要这么做。听听这门人生必修课，
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你收听播客的任何地方搜索《艰难成长的教训》。2%。这是当电梯旁也有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是“TWO%”，在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你收听播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子交往过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他一定会付出应有的代价。我们总是说，要相信你的好闺蜜们。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝，在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你收听播客的任何地方。在《回顾过往》（Look Back at It）播客节目中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners,
和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你收听播客的任何地方收听《回顾过往》。大家好，欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个我们探讨二十几岁时遭遇的人生重大改变和转折，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎新老听众回到这个播客，
wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. I am so very excited for today's episode because it's a little bit different from our usual content. It kind of marries, I would say, my two podcasts together in a way. If you guys didn't know, I have another podcast called Mantra, which I describe as like the spiritual little sister of the psychology of your 20s. We go in depth into a lot of the stuff we talk about here, but from a more philosophical perspective. And you know, it may be a little bit woo-woo for some, but I really like having that added depth and like the nuances of those conversations to kind of give things a new angle. And today we're kind of diving more into
无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，当然，我们也将一如既往地剖析二十岁的心理。我非常期待今天的节目，因为它和我们通常的内容有点不同。可以说，它在某种程度上把我的两个播客结合在了一起。如果大家还不知道的话，我还有另一个播客叫《真言》（Mantra），我把它描述为《二十岁心理学》的精神小妹妹。我们会深入探讨很多在这里讨论过的内容，但会从一个更哲学的角度来看待。你知道，对某些人来说可能有点玄学，但我真的很喜欢这种增加的深度以及那些对话的细微差别，从而给事物带来一个新的角度。而今天，我们有点像是在深入探讨
that realm and taking a more kind of astrological spiritual take on our 20s. And we're, but of course still with like a scientific lens to it. We are talking about an idea that if you are in your late 20s, maybe on the brink of 30 you have heard about before, it is the idea of Saturn's return. So this concept of Saturn returns, firstly, so many of you have asked me for this question, but secondly, it's really having a moment. It comes up so much in pop culture, especially in songs.
那个领域，对我们的二十岁采取一种更偏向占星和精神层面的视角。当然，我们仍然会用科学的镜头来看待它。我们要讨论的是一个概念——如果你正处于二十岁末期、或许正濒临三十岁，你以前一定听说过它，它就是“土星回归”（Saturn's return）。所以，关于土星回归这个概念，首先，你们中有很多人都问过我这个问题；其次，它现在真的很火。它在流行文化中经常出现，特别是在歌曲中。
You know, scissors song, satin, satin, I think it's just called satin. Casey Musgrove's song, Deepa Well, I know Ariana Grande has a song about it on her new album. And in each of these songs, you know, these artists talk about this pivotal moment that they've each uniquely experienced in which at 27, 28, 29, their lives just suddenly shocked them and kind of just completely did 180. It's actually a rather common experience for people at this age to just go through a magnificent, completely unpredictable life shift. And if you believe the theory, it is something that actually all of us must go through. All of us are going to have some form of this experience. The idea of Saturn returns comes from astrology. It basically represents a astrological event whereby Saturn, the planet,
你知道的，SZA的歌《Saturn》，我想它就叫《Saturn》。凯西·马斯格雷夫斯的歌《Deepa Well》，我知道爱莉安娜·格兰德在她新专辑里也有一首歌是关于这个的。在每一首歌里，你知道的，这些艺术家都在谈论这个他们各自独特经历的关键时刻：在27、28、29岁时，他们的生活突然给了他们当头一棒，经历了一个180度的大转弯。对于这个年龄段的人来说，经历一场宏大且完全不可预测的生活转变其实是一种相当普遍的体验。如果你相信这种理论，这就是我们所有人实际上都必须经历的事情。我们所有人都会经历某种形式的这种体验。土星回归的概念源于占星术。它基本上代表了一个占星事件，即作为行星的土星，
returns to its same position as when you were born right as you exit your 20s and enter your 30s. And that's what brings, according to this theory, so many unique shifts. Breakups, lost, new career pathways. major identity shifts, all these things are what we can expect from this period. But there is, of course, as always, a psychological explanation to the inevitability of these events that we also need to discuss. So today, I'm going to offer this psychological breakdown and psychological perspective on the return of Saturn on this exciting chapter, what you can expect, why everything suddenly changes, the developmental explanation, the scientific one,
在你即将告别二十岁、跨入三十岁之际，回到了你出生时的那个相同位置。而正是这一点，根据这个理论，带来了如此多独特的转变。分手、失落、新的职业道路。重大的身份转变，这些都是我们可以从这段时期预期的东西。但是，正如往常一样，这些事件的不可避免性背后，当然也存在着我们需要探讨的心理学解释。所以今天，我要在这期节目中提供关于土星回归的心理学剖析和心理学视角，探讨这个激动人心的篇章、你可以期待什么、为什么一切会突然改变、发展心理学上的解释、科学上的解释，
and most importantly, for those of you going through it right now, how to make the most out of this period, how to get through this. We're also going to talk about the history of the concept. We're going to talk about Roman and Greek mythology. I know so many fun things. And stories of people who have made it out on the other side, plus so much more. So even if you don't think that astrology is for you, believe me, I'm also very skeptical. I do think that you'll be surprised by how much of this might. just apply to your life and what you might learn. So without further ado, let's dive into
最重要的是，对于那些正经历这一时期的人来说，如何充分利用这段时间，如何度过难关。我们还将探讨这个概念的历史。我们要聊聊罗马和希腊神话。我知道有好多有趣的东西。还有那些成功挺过来的人的故事，以及更多内容。所以，即使你认为占星术不适合你，相信我，我自己也非常怀疑。但我认为，你会惊讶地发现，其中有多少内容可能恰好适用于你的生活，又能让你有所启发。废话不多说，让我们深入探讨
the psychology of Saturn's return. Okay, so let's get the simple stuff out of the way. What is a Saturn return? I've kind of already given a very light explanation, but Saturn return is basically when the planet Saturn circles back to the same position in the sky that it occupied the moment that you were born. Now, because Saturn roughly takes about 27 to 30 years, to complete an orbit around the sun, your Saturn return tends to land at around 27 to 30. Some people say earlier it can happen at 26, it can happen up to 31, depending on when you are born. And it doesn't just happen in one moment.
土星回归的心理学。好吧，那我们先抛开那些简单的部分。什么是土星回归？我刚才其实已经做了一个非常简单的解释，但土星回归基本上就是指土星这颗行星在太空中运行，回到了你出生那一刻它所占据的同一位置。现在，因为土星绕太阳一周大约需要27到30年，所以你的土星回归往往会出现在你27到30岁左右。有些人说得早一点，可能在26岁，也可能一直延续到31岁，这取决于你的出生时间。而且它不是只发生在某一个瞬间。
It's not just like a second. It is a season. It is a season that sometimes stretches two to three years. It is a process of build up and fall out that kind of decimates our lives in a way, but sometimes for the best. Saturn return, you don't actually just have one. Some people could have three. Most people have about two.
它不只是像一秒钟那样的事。它是一个时期。这是一个有时会持续两到三年的时期。这是一个积聚和爆发的过程，在某种程度上会彻底摧毁我们的生活，但有时这反而是件好事。土星回归，其实你并不只经历一次。有些人可能会经历三次。大多数人大约会经历两次。
Around the age of 58 to 60, you experience another one again. And then around the age of 80 to 90, if you're lucky enough, is when you'll experience perhaps your final one. Each return is said to Mark a new kind of stage in life. The first one is the shift into true adulthood. The second is the shift into elder wisdom. and the third is the shift into legacy, and a lot will change during these periods.
在大约58到60岁时，你会再次经历一次。然后在大约80到90岁时，如果你足够幸运的话，你可能会经历最后一次。据说每一次回归都标志着人生一个新的阶段的开始。第一次是从真正迈向成年；第二次是从步入长者的智慧；第三次是从转向留下精神遗产，在这些时期里，很多事情都会发生改变。
So we know the pop culture references to Saturn returns, but historically references to this cycle go way back to ancient Roman and Greek astrology where Saturn or Kronos in Greece wasn't just a planet, it was a god that represented discipline, restriction, boundaries, and time itself. The god Saturn also represents. agriculture, wealth, the seasons, partying. So he had a lot of hats. He had a lot of hats. But astrologically, the planet of Saturn is considered kind of a task master planet. So a task master planet, I didn't know this before researching this episode, basically signifies
所以我们知道流行文化中对土星回归的引用，但从历史上看，对这个周期的引用可以追溯到古罗马和古希腊占星术，在那里，土星或希腊神话中的克洛诺斯（Kronos）不仅仅是一颗行星，它还是一个代表着纪律、限制、界限和时间本身的神。神明土星还代表着农业、财富、四季、狂欢。所以他有很多重身份。他有很多重身份。但在占星术中，土星这颗行星被认为是一种“严厉考验”的行星。那么，严厉考验的行星——在研究这一期节目之前我并不知道这一点——基本上意味着
calmic lessons. It's a planet that's responsible or influences how we face our limits, how we face reality, how we face the things that we perhaps avoided. And so in astrology speak, Saturn return, all of this comes to this point whereby you confront the structures that you've built in your 20s and you are tested on them. And you have to determine whether they are truly yours or they are borrowed from other people's expectations. And this is why our life feels like it kind of falls apart. Even if it's not noticeable, things are going to change for you.
业力法则的教训。这是一颗负责或影响我们如何面对自身局限、如何面对现实、如何面对我们可能一直在逃避的事物的行星。因此，用占星术的话来说，土星回归，这一切都汇聚到了这样一个节点：你直面自己在二十多岁时建立的各种结构，并接受它们的考验。你必须确定这些究竟真的是属于你的，还是借用了别人的期望。这就是为什么我们的生活感觉有点土崩瓦解。即使它不那么明显，事情也必定会为你发生改变。
It is a coming of age. And it's actually an opportunity to put a positive spin on it, to create a life that really aligns with your deeper purpose and your deeper goals. So the modern popularization of Saturn and Saturn returns really started in the 20th century, particularly with the boom of astrology in the 1960s and 70s, when psychics, tarot cards, fortune tellers, like that industry exploded. It's definitely had a renaissance though in the past decade, obviously due to pop culture, but also due to social media where people have started to name this experience using this label
这是一个成年礼。它其实是一个机会，能让你对它抱有积极的看法，去创造一种真正符合你更深层目标和更深层追求的生活。因此，土星和土星回归的现代普及真正始于20世纪，特别是在20世纪60和70年代占星术的繁荣时期，当时灵媒、塔罗牌、算命这类行业呈爆炸式增长。不过在过去十年里，它绝对经历了一次复兴，这显然是因为流行文化，但也因为社交媒体，人们开始用这个标签来命名这段经历，
and it's really validated for a lot of people, the chaos that they have come to experience or are experiencing in their late 20s. Maybe Saturn returns is just a metaphor for the things. that we are enduring. Let's zoom out a little bit. Why are we so drawn to this explanation? Why do we like explanations like this in general of astrology, of numerology, of cycles, of fate, or the idea that life comes in seasons, because that's what this really is. First off, the reason that we like the idea of a Saturn returns or anything of this sort is that we are meaning-making creatures. When things are uncertain, like early adulthood, like, early adulthood,
对于许多人来说，这确实证实了他们在二十多岁末期所经历或正在经历的混乱。也许土星回归只是一种隐喻，代表着我们正在忍受的事情。让我们把视角稍微拉远一点。为什么我们如此被这种解释所吸引？为什么我们总喜欢像占星术、命理学、周期、命运，或者生活是有季节的这种概念的解释，因为这才是这背后的本质。首先，我们喜欢土星回归或任何类似概念的想法的原因在于，我们是会赋予事物意义的生物。当事情充满不确定性时，比如刚步入成年的时候，比如，刚步入成年的时候，
like our 20s. Having a framework can really soothe us. Frameworks, however arbitrary, they do actually provide a psychological feeling of safety and a narrative by which we can live. We like patterns because they give us a sense of control. Even if life feels terrible and scary, you can feel like, okay, well, maybe this is supposed to happen right now because of this explanation that someone is giving me. And that is why our belief in these systems actually does tend to increase in our 20s, when we are desperate in many ways for structured external systems and explanations for why life is like hitting all of these ups and downs.
比如我们二十多岁的时候。有一个框架确实可以抚慰我们。框架无论多么武断，实际上确实能提供一种心理上的安全感，以及一个我们可以依循生活的叙事。我们喜欢模式，因为它们给了我们一种掌控感。即使生活感觉糟糕透顶、令人恐惧，你也会觉得：“好吧，也许因为某个人给我的这种解释，这件事现在就是注定要发生的。”这就是为什么我们对这些系统的信仰往往会在二十多岁时增加，那时我们在许多方面都极其渴望结构化的外部系统，以及关于为什么生活会经历所有这些起起落落的解释。
There is literally a whole field of psychology dedicated to this idea of meaning making, and it's called narrative psychology. This field basically says that humans' identities and our understanding of the world and the world around us, like it is constructed through stories and the stories we tell ourselves. How you experience a breakup will be determined by the story of your relationship. How you relate to your siblings is determined by the story of your childhood. How you approach risk is determined by stories or folk stories of what this really means and what we need to go through. and what the stars are telling us or what the universe is telling us. In this way, astrology is a symbolic storytelling system,
实际上，心理学中有一个专门的领域致力于研究这种“赋予意义”的理念，它被称为叙事心理学。这个领域基本上认为，人类的身份认同以及我们对世界和周围世界的理解，是通过故事以及我们讲给自己的故事构建起来的。你如何经历一场分手，将取决于你对这段感情的故事的定义。你如何与兄弟姐妹相处，取决于你童年的故事。你如何对待风险，取决于关于这意味着什么、我们需要经历什么的传说或民间故事，
which provides us with a really meaningful narrative for life. Whether it is real or not, like I'm not going to make any statements either way. It doesn't actually matter. It doesn't matter if it's real. It's the comfort that it provides us. And anything that, you know, is real that comes from that or that comes from the stars is kind of just a bonus in my mind. So let's talk about what actually tends to happen in this Saturn return season, because the astrological
以及星星或宇宙在向我们传达什么。从这个意义上说，占星术是一个象征性的故事讲述系统，它为我们的生活提供了一个非常有意义的叙事。不管它是真是假——反正我也不会做任何绝对的表态。其实这并不重要。它是不是真的并不重要。重要的是它给我们带来的安慰。而任何由此产生的、或是从星空中汲取的真实感，在我看来其实都只是一种额外的奖赏。所以，让我们来聊聊在土星回归这个时期到底往往会发生什么，因为占星术的解释是一回事，
explanation is one thing, but there is also a very solid psychological side to all of this. And that's where this idea of emerging adulthood becomes important to understand. Jeffrey Arnott, he is a developmental psychologist. He coined the term emerging adulthood to basically describe the period between 18 and 29. that is for a lot of people an in-between stage where you are not a teenager anymore, but you may not be fully settled into what most people think of as adulthood either. Now, at this stage, a few things start to happen to us because of changing expectations, because of how our brain is developing, because of, you know, external things.
但所有这一切背后，也存在一个非常坚实的心理学层面。这就是“成年期过渡”（emerging adulthood）这个概念变得重要且需要理解的地方。杰弗里·阿奈特（Jeffrey Arnett）是一位发展心理学家。他创造了“成年期过渡”这个词，来大致描述18岁到29岁之间的这段时期，对许多人来说，这是一个过渡阶段，你不再是个青少年，但可能也没有完全定型为大多数人所认为的成年人。现在，在这个阶段，由于期望的改变、大脑的发育以及外部事物的因素，一些事情开始在我们身上发生。
Mainly, we start to feel like we need to get more serious about this adult thing, but also we still have a lot of unanswered questions and things that we need to learn. And those two truths, the need to know and the not knowing, start to clash against each other. Let's start with the impact of this confusion on our relationships. For a lot of people, relationships are at the front and center of this period in their 20s, romantic ones especially. You will see this happening, and I have seen this happening quite regularly. you might have been with someone since you were 22 and by 28 you're realizing that a person,
主要是，我们开始觉得我们需要对“成年”这件事更认真一点，但与此同时，我们仍然有很多未解的问题和需要学习的东西。而这两种真相——对知道答案的需求与对未知的无知——开始互相碰撞。让我们从这种困惑对我们人际关系的影响开始说起。对许多人来说，关系处于他们二十多岁这段时期的核心位置，尤其是浪漫关系。你会看到这种情况发生，而我也经常看到这种情况发生。你可能从22岁起就和某个人在一起了，到了28岁，你突然意识到这个人，
this person isn't quite the same match to you as you were when you first started dating. This is why breakups around this age is so common. You're kind of at this turning point. Either we commit and we make this for the rest of our lives or we have this opportunity to really have our last moment of being single in our 20s or find someone new and it feels like this is the point where we have to decide. I can think of literally four people off the top of my head who I know who have broken up with their partner of four plus years
这个人已经不像你们刚开始约会时那样与你那么般配了。这就是为什么这个年龄段的分手如此普遍。你正处在这个转折点。要么我们承诺厮守终生，要么我们就有机会迎来单身在二十多岁的最后一个高光时刻，或者寻找新的人，而这感觉就像是我们必须做出决定的时刻。我脑海里随口就能想过去这一年里，就在他们快满30岁之前，
right before they turned 30 in the past year alone. It is a huge phenomena. Psychologists even track this theory and can track this pattern of relationship dissolution in the late 20s and they suggest that many long-term relationships either end or transition into marriage during this period. And it's actually quite a normal turning point for people. It's one of the most common times and time periods
和交往了四年多的伴侣分手的四个活生生的人。这是一个巨大的现象。心理学家甚至追踪了这一理论，并能追踪到二十多岁末期关系破裂的这种模式，他们表明许多长期关系在这段时期要么走向终结，要么过渡到婚姻。对于人们来说，这其实是一个相当正常的转折点。这是人们最有可能分道扬镳、各奔东西的最常见的时间段之一。所以，如果你在二十多岁末期或土星回归期间经历了一场真正震撼的、糟糕的、粉碎生活的分手，其实这并不罕见，
when people are likely to split up and to go their own way. So if you have been through a really seismic, terrible, life-shattering breakup at the end of your 20s or during your sat in return, it's actually not that uncommon. and is actually probably a good thing that you have made this decision at this moment. Another really famous theory comes from Eric Erickson. We talk about him a lot. He's a German-American psychoanalyst.
而且在你生命的这个时刻做出这个决定，大概率也是一件好事。另一个非常著名的理论来自埃里克·埃里克森（Erik Erikson）。我们经常谈论他。他是一位德裔美国精神分析学家。
And he says that the reason this happens is because we are moving through what we call an intimacy versus isolation stage of development at this point in time. So as we enter our late 20s, we do start to develop a much more secure sense of self and identity. It's something that we all look forward to, you know, the older we get. We know ourselves more. This newfound self-awareness, that is what begins to expose fundamental incompatibilities that were maybe tolerated or overlooked when you were younger. You may have built your identity around this partner or this person or may have been something together, but as you have found yourself more as you have created your own independent identity just by aging, you realize like this
他说，之所以会出现这种情况，是因为我们在这一时期正经历着我们所说的“亲密对孤独”（intimacy versus isolation）的发展阶段。因此，当我们进入二十多岁末期时，我们确实开始对自我和身份认同有了更稳固的感知。这是我们随着年龄增长、愈发期待的事情。我们更了解自己了。这种新发现的自我觉醒，正是开始暴露出那些你在年轻时可能会容忍或忽视的根本性不兼容。你可能围绕着这个伴侣或这个人构建了自己的身份，或者你们曾经是一起建立的某些东西，但随着你通过变老更多地发现了自我，你意识到这个人
person isn't for me. You need space. You may ultimately need to break up. As as well, you know, the expectation to get married or settled down becomes louder. I think you also start to have to answer some very existential questions. Like, do I want to be loved this way for the rest of my life? If this is all that love will ever be, is this enough? and by golly gosh, like you need to answer that question now. And I know it creates such a sense of impending doom and such a sense of like literal terror. But it's required of you so that you don't end up in these situations. We see all the time of people in loveless marriages or with people they really knew they weren't went to be with years and years down the line wishing that at 28 they just cut their losses to sound completely callous.
并不适合我。你需要空间。你最终可能需要分手。同样地，你知道的，结婚或安定下来的期望也变得越来越响亮。我想你还得开始回答一些非常存在主义的问题。比如，我想余生都被这样去爱吗？如果这就是爱的全部意义，这够吗？天呐，你必须现在就回答这个问题。我知道这会带来一种厄运临头的末日感，以及字面意义上的极度恐惧。但这是你必须面对的，这样你才不会最终落入那种境地。我们总是看到许多人在毫无爱意的婚姻中，或者和那些他们多年前就知道并不适合的人在一起，多年以后，他们只希望自己在28岁时能够及时止损，哪怕听起来有些冷酷无情。
It's not just romantic relationships. Friendships shift in big ways during this time as well. Remember how in your teens and even early 20s, friendships were like, they were inbuilt, right? You didn't really have to try. It was definitely from a place of convenience. School, roommates, shared experiences, shared hobbies. You could always find someone there.
不仅是浪漫关系。友情在这期间也会发生巨大的转变。还记得你在十几岁甚至二十岁出头的时候，友情是怎么样的吗？它们就像是内置的，对吧？你其实根本不需要去刻意经营。它绝对来自于便利性。学校、室友、共同的经历、共同的爱好。你总能在那里找到某个人。
As we get older, as we move, as we take up jobs, as we couple up, as we have kids, friendships suddenly require a real intention maintenance and a lot of people will hit the mid-20s late-20s mark having had people fall off kind of in trickles for a while and look around and be like oh there's no one left i'm deeply lonely had this moment myself recently and like i feel like i talk about loneliness a lot on the podcast and it's been like an ongoing you know battle with me but i just had this moment where a lot of my friends have moved overseas. Like three of my best friends have moved overseas in the last six
随着我们年龄的增长，随着我们搬家、找工作、开始恋爱、有了孩子，友谊突然需要真正的刻意维持，很多人在走到二十多岁中后期时，会经历朋友逐渐零星流失的一段时期，然后环顾四周，发现：“哦，一个人都不剩了，我感到无比孤独。”我最近自己就经历了这样的时刻，而且我觉得我在播客里经常谈论孤独，这就像是我一直在进行的一场战斗，但我刚刚经历了这样一个时刻：我的很多朋友都搬到海外去了。就像我最好的三个朋友在过去六
months. And I was like, wow, my my friendship circle and my network is a lot thinner than it used to. And there's a lot of panic in that. There's a lot of panic in being like, do I want it to remain this way? Or do I want to do something, try things to change that? Again, the research consistently backs this up. For example, in a meta-analysis of over 270 studies, research has found that on average social networks decrease in size as people age the steepest decline occurs at this point right now in young adulthood in our late 20s early 30s there's a lot of circumstantial reasons for this but basically if we think about it our lives generally get busier and typically like the effort that we feel we can reasonably put into our friendships
个月里都搬到海外去了。当时我就想：“哇，我的朋友圈和人际网络比以前单薄多了。”这里面充满了恐慌。当你面对这种情况时，会产生很多恐慌：“我想让它一直这样下去吗？还是我想做点什么，尝试改变现状？”同样，研究始终支持这一点。例如，在一项针对270多项研究的元分析中，研究发现，平均而言，随着人们年龄的增长，社交网络的规模会缩短，而最急剧的下降就发生在当前这个年轻成人的阶段——也就是我们的二十岁末期到三十岁初期。这背后有很多客观原因，但基本上，如果我们仔细想想，我们的生活通常会变得更加忙碌，而且通常来说，我们觉得能够合理投入到友谊中的精力
becomes a lot smaller. And it's why you have less friends. It's why you might find yourself being very lonely. Now it doesn't mean that that's like going to happen and be the way for the rest of your life. I think it is again the wake up call. Do I want to live like this for the next 50 years? Okay, we're going to take a short break here. But when we come back, we're going to talk family.
变得少得多了。这就是为什么你的朋友变少了。这就是为什么你可能会发现自己非常孤独。现在，这并不意味着这种情况会一直持续下去，成为你余生的常态。我认为这同样是一个警钟。我想以这种方式度过接下来的50年吗？好了，我们要在这里稍事休息。但当我们回来时，我们将聊聊家庭。
We're going to talk career. We're going to talk identity. And also how to overcome. the tumultuous period of your sat in return. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我们要聊聊职业。我们要聊聊身份。以及如何克服土星回归这段动荡不安的时期。请继续收听。2%。那是当电梯旁也有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross
我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是T-W-O-Persent，在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你收听播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯
double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English.
在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过往》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. clear 84 is big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）合作的节目，大谈80年代的“快克”毒品。84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我一整天都可以聊快克，不过为了让大家知道，我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目了。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts.
所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在还把艾滋病摆上了台面。谢谢你把这句话说完。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts收听《回顾过往》
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
或你收听播客的任何地方。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难成长的教训》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域超过十年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
我说的就是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，在我们追求某样东西的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的游戏。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹只是去成为一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, iHeartRadio app search Learn the Hard Way and listen now. In 2023,
加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，让我们在我的新播客《艰难成长的教训》中，就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标进行真正的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio App，搜索《艰难成长的教训》并立即收听。在2023年，
former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's,
前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。你在这份特定的测试中造假了两次，对吗？我造假了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。
correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini.
我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的杀毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两个经历过同样事情的男性：格雷格·莱斯皮安（Greg Lespian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的脑子都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud, Charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这件事不算完。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你收听播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。所以我们已经讨论了土星回归给我们的恋爱关系和友情带来的变化。还有我们的家庭，以及人生这个阶段动态的转变如何真正爆发并演变成这种非常独特的、
Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So we've talked about the changes that Satin Return brings up for our relationships and for our friendships. And then there's our family and how shifting dynamics during this period of our life can really explode out into this very unique kind of. of relationship. I think this one can kind of sneak up on you. In your early 20s, I think family is like background noise. Like you're kind of out in the world. You're like living your own life. Maybe you're like calling home once in a while, like you visit on the holidays. It's a very common thing that around your late 20s, often like the role of your family comes rushing back to the front row and we kind of turn around, do this orbit and rely on them suddenly almost as much as we did
关系。我觉得这种转变有时候会悄悄找上你。在二十岁出头时，我觉得家庭就像是背景噪音。就像你置身于外部世界。你过着自己的生活。也许你偶尔给家里打个电话，节假日回家探亲。通常情况下，大约在二十多岁末期，家庭的角色往往会猛然回到前排，我们转过身，完成这个公转，突然间开始依赖他们，几乎就像我们小时候依赖他们那样，特别是在情感上。对我们许多人来说，这也是父母老去的现实开始降临的时刻。你会开始注意到一些小细节。
when we were children for a lot of things, especially emotionally. For many of us, this is also when the reality of like aging parents starts to land. Like you do start to notice little things. Like your dad's memory is slipping or your mom gets tired more easily or, you know, you have this moment where you celebrate, you celebrate like a huge milestone birthday for your grandparents and are like, huh, I don't think they have many years left. It's also when a lot of people experience real serious loss. Some people experience it earlier, which is heartbreaking, but I think this is when a lot of people start to lose parents or they start to really see serious declines in their well-being that forces you to reckon not just with like the fragility of life and of their lives, but like,
比如你父亲的记忆力在衰退，或者你母亲更容易感到疲惫，或者，你知道的，你经历了一个时刻，你为祖父母庆祝了一个重大的里程碑生日，然后心想：“呃，我觉得他们没剩几年了。”这也是许多人经历真正严重的丧亲之痛的时期。有些人经历得更早，这令人心碎，但我认为这是许多人开始失去父母，或者真正看到他们健康状况严重恶化的时候，这迫使你不仅要正视生命以及他们生命的脆弱性，而且还要正视存在本身的脆弱性，正视认真对待事情、在时间有限时真正去追求你想要的东西是多么重要。这再次引发了大量的、宏大的存在主义问题，所有这些都回到了我们脑海深处盘旋的这种质疑中。对我们中的一些人来说，这也是你第一次真正体验到照顾他人滋味的时候。
yeah, the fragility of existence and how serious it is to take things seriously and to like really go after what you want when time is finite. That's a lot of a, again, big esthetic. existential questions, all of it is coming back to this questioning that's like in the back of our mind. For some of us as well, this is like the first time where you get a real taste of like caregiving. Maybe you start helping with bills, with doctor's appointments. Maybe you become like a steady emotional support. And this role reversal can feel disorientating, right? There's actually a phrase called philalalilal maturity. Is it philalalilal? I don't know how to pronounce it. You know when you only ever see a word written down, someone's going to correct me in the
也许你开始帮忙支付账单、陪同去看医生。也许你成了稳定的情感支柱。这种角色的逆转会让人感到迷失方向，对吧？实际上有一个词叫“filalalilal maturity”（成年子女对父母的心理成熟）。是叫filalalilal吗？我不知道该怎么发音。你知道当你只见过一个词的拼写时就会这样，总会有人在评论区纠正我的。我就叫它“filial maturity”（成年子女的心理成熟）吧。它基本上描述了这样一个精确的阶段：成年后的子女变成了他们父母的“父母”。他们开始真正把自己的照顾者看作是有血有肉的完整的人。你知道的，你不再对他们抱有“他们是无所不能的”那种幻想。
comments. I'm going to go with filial, filial maturity. And it basically describes this exact stage when, like, the adult child becomes the parent to their parent. And they start to really see their caregivers as whole people. You know, you no longer have that, like, fantasy of them being invincible. Like, they have limits. They have flaws. They need you to take care of them. It's really, really bittersweet and very difficult because you have to kind of acknowledge that there's this new role you're entering as this adult who may have to do this alone at some stage and who has to come to terms with the fact that time is passing and this person might not always be there. But family work isn't just about your immediate family and your parents. It's also like
他们也有极限。他们也有缺点。他们需要你来照顾他们。这真的是苦乐参半，也非常困难，因为你不得不承认，你正在进入这个新角色，作为一个成年人，你可能在某个阶段必须独自面对这一切，并且你必须接受这样一个事实：时间在流逝，这个人可能不会永远陪伴在你身边。但家庭方面的功课并不只限于你的核心家庭和父母。这也是我们开始质疑的时候：我想要自己的家庭吗？我想要孩子吗？你知道的，这是你第一次可以真正暂作思考。我知道很多人在更年轻的时候就有了孩子，但特别是在我们这一代人当中，我觉得我们花了很多二十岁出头的时间在想：“自由万岁！我要去探索，我要去尝试各种事情，我要试着不要像我可能想的那样或应该的那样把这一切看得太重。我要去享受快乐。”
when we start to question like, do I want my own family? Do I want kids? You know, know, this is the first time where you can really zone out. And I know a lot of people like have children younger, but especially in this generation, I feel like we spend a lot of our early 20s being like, freedom, yay, like I'm going to be exploratory and I'm going to just try things out and like, I'm going to try and not take this all as seriously as maybe I want to or I should. And I'm going to have fun. And then it's like you get to 27 and you're like, I need to start answering some big questions and whether I want kids, whether I'm capable of being a parent, whether I've dealt with my family shit enough to be good in this role, again, it's like landing straight in
然后当你到了27岁时，你就会想：“我需要开始回答一些重大问题了，比如我是否想要孩子，我是否有能力成为一个父母，我是否已经很好地处理了家庭的那堆烂摊子，以至于能够在这个角色中表现良好。”再次说明，这就像是直接砸到了你的腿上，同时还有一百万件其他的事情全都在同一时间发生。这就是为什么土星回归通常被称为一个累积的过程，对吧？它不只是分手。不只是友谊的解体。不只是关于我对未来有什么期望的重大问题。接着是家庭。接着是关于你身份认同的问题。当然，还有职业。如果我们不谈论我们在职业身份和工作上将经历的转变，我们就无法谈论土星回归以及它会对我们产生什么影响。这一点至关重要。
your lap along with like a million other things all happening at the same time. This is why like sat in return is often referred to as like a cumulative process, right? It's not just the breakup. It's not just the friendship, you know, dissolution. It's not just the big questions about what do I want from my future. It's then family. It's then questions about your identity. And of course, also Korea. Like we cannot talk about sat in return and what it will do to us if we do not talk about the shifts that we will experience in our professional identity and at work. This one is huge. In early 20s, experimentation, first jobs, internships, trying things out.
在二十岁出头时，进行各种尝试、第一份工作、实习、摸索。这倒不是说有多严重。它可能会很严重。但它不一定是永久性的。然后就像是时钟一直在倒计时，你突然想到：“天啊，我突然必须做出决定了。”试用期结束了。我是要全身心投入这种生活，还是要选择别的东西？这就是我想做的吗？这真的是我想要的吗？
It's not that serious. It might be serious. It's not necessarily permanent. Then it's like the clock has been counting down and you're like, oh my God, suddenly I have to make a decision. The trial period is over. Am I going to commit to this life or am I going to choose something else? Is this what I want to do? Is this really it?
有些人彻底转型，我看到过朋友这样做，看他们转型简直是一种奇妙的体验：他们重返校园、创业、追逐创意项目。其他人则变得更加严肃，开始加倍努力，考虑在公司职场上往上爬。但几乎所有人都会在职业生涯的这个时刻感受到这种冲击：面对被困住的感觉、对更多意义的需求、对未来的恐慌。实际上，《职业行为杂志》（Journal of Vocational Behavior）上有一项研究，追踪了二十多岁末期（大约28到30岁）的人群，发现那些在工作中感到最不满意的人，不一定是因为工作本身不好。他们很多人赚得不错，但问题在于这些工作并不符合他们个人所认同的价值观。
some people pivot completely and I have seen friends do this and it's been marvelous to watch they go back to school they start businesses they chase creative projects others just get more serious and they start to double down and think about climbing the corporate ladder but almost everyone will feel this at this moment in their career of confronting feelings of feeling stuck of needing more meaning of panicking about their future there's actually a study from the Journal of Vocational Behavior that followed people in their late 20s around 28 to 30 and found that those who felt most dissatisfied at work weren't necessarily in bad jobs. A lot of them were making good money, but it was that these jobs didn't line up with what they were recognizing that they
换句话说，你知道的，他们在乎创造力，但他们做的工作只在乎效率；他们渴望目标，但他们的工作却只提供了一张不错的薪水支票，除此之外什么都没有。这种不匹配正是带来痛苦的根源。而这种痛苦往往会在这个年龄左右达到顶峰，这时我们终于开始把我们以为自己会过的生活与我们实际正在过的生活进行比较。这种不满意的一部分原因也仅仅归结于老掉牙的地理位置。环境在土星回归阶段扮演着非常重要的角色。我和我的朋友们之间有一个笑话，那就是澳大利亚的每个人一到27岁就会搬去伦敦。因为天啊，这看起来似乎是一个太普遍的模式了。我也正准备这么做。我都无法，
personally valued. In other words, you know, they cared about creativity, but they were only doing a job that cared about efficiency. They craved purpose, but, you know, their job only offered a good paycheck and nothing else. The mismatch is where the discomfort is coming from. And it does tend to come to a head right around this age when we are finally comparing the life we thought we'd have with the one that we're actually living. Part of that to satisfaction also links to just like plain old geography. Environment plays a really big role in the satin return stage. There's this like joke that me and my friends have that everyone in Australia turns 27 and moves to London. Because oh my God, like it just seems like such a common pattern. I'm doing it. Like I can't even,
就像我自己成了自己笑话里的梗。我要搬去伦敦了。我觉得在这个阶段，你的内心有一种巨大的呼唤，让你忍不住想：“在我对我目前的生活点击‘立即购买’之前，让我看看外面还有什么。”二十多岁末期是搬家的高峰期，无论是在物理地理上还是在心理上。而且我们的性格也会发生转变。人们经常引用这样一种观点，即大脑在25岁时完全成熟。这其实是不准确的。你之所以可能会经历许多动荡，部分原因在于，你期望自己能进入一种更成熟、更聪明、更会思考的系统。
like I am the butt of my own joke. Like I'm moving to London. I felt like there's this big call in you at this stage to just be like, let me see what else is out there before I click by now on the life that I currently have. The late 20s are like a hot spot for moving both physically and psychologically. And we're also going to see our personality shift as well. People often quote this idea that like the brain fully matures at 25. That's actually not correct. Part of the reason why you might be experiencing a lot of like tumultuousness is because, you know, you expect to feel like you have locked into this more mature, smarter thinking system.
就像我在拿自己开玩笑一样。比如我要搬去伦敦。我觉得在这个阶段，你的内心有一种强烈的呼唤，只想去看看外面还有什么，然后再决定买下我目前的生活。快到20岁末期的时候，就像是身体上和心理上都要发生搬迁的热点时期。而且我们也会看到自己的性格发生转变。人们经常引用这样一种观点，即大脑在25岁时完全成熟。这其实是不对的。你之所以会经历很多动荡，部分原因是因为，你知道，你期望自己感觉已经锁定了一个更成熟、更聪明的思考系统。
But actually, you are going to experience another rapid burst of pruning and changes in your brain that will influence your personality in your life. in your late 20s. In our late 20s, a lot of us become slightly more conscientious. We tend to become more responsible, more reliable, simply because we are adapting to the increasing roles that we are facing in our lives. But along with that, comes a heavier awareness of the limits of this change. You can't do anything. You can't be everything. And that's where this like creeping feeling of like premature failure can show up, this nagging feeling. of like I should have had it all figured out. And how we respond to that can actually be quite irrational. So everyone's saying like you get more mature, you're able to make more mature decisions
但实际上，在20多岁快结束时，你们的大脑将经历另一轮快速的修剪和重组，这会影响你的人生性格。在20多岁接近尾声时，我们中的很多人会变得更有责任心一点。我们往往会变得更有责任感、更可靠，这纯粹是因为我们在适应生活中不断增加的角色。但随之而来的，是对这种转变局限性的更深感知。你不可能什么都做。你不可能面面俱到。这就是那种隐隐的、未老先衰的失败感开始出现的地方，那种挥之不去的烦恼。就好像我本该把一切都弄清楚一样。而我们对此的反应实际上可能相当不理性。所以每个人都说，你变得更成熟了，你能够做出更成熟的决定
and be more straightforward with your life. Then there is this final burst, often in our late 20s where we might call it an extinction burst, we might call it rallying, where right before we feel like we've locked into like our new and mature brain, right before like we feel like we feel like we feel like we're going to retire this part of our life. We revisit it one more time and we go out with a bang. Dan McAdams, he is this researcher who studies narrative identity. He has written about how around 29, many people have what he calls a redemptive turning point. It's that moment when the story you've been telling yourself for most of your 20s, like you just are like, don't don't want it anymore. Or you're like, if I'm going to finish this story, I'm going to go off on a
并且对生活更坦诚。然后是这最后一次井喷，通常在我们20多岁快结束时，我们可能会称之为绝境井喷，我们可能会称之为回光返照，就在我们觉得自己仿佛锁定了新的成熟大脑之前，就在我们觉得自己仿佛要告别这部分生活之前。我们再次重温它，然后轰轰烈烈地结束。丹·麦克亚当斯（Dan McAdams），他是研究叙事认同的研究人员。他曾写道，在大约29岁时，许多人会经历他所说的“救赎转折点”。就是那个时刻，你在20多岁的大部分时间里一直在对自己讲述的故事，比如你突然就，不再想要它了。或者你会想，如果我要完成这个故事，我要在结束之前去经历一个
major tangent before I do. A lot of people have this moment where their like their personality almost regresses or returns to an earlier stage before it like comes back for like its final moment. And it's not to say that like once you turn 30 like you're locked down. This is who you're going to be for the rest of your life. No, your brain continues to develop your personality actually does continue to change for the rest of your life. But this is just one of those moments where like you really see like a spike or like a differentiation in activity. So if Saturn return, your Saturn return feels like everything is changing,
重大的转折。很多人都有这样一刻，他们的性格几乎会退化或回到早期阶段，然后才会回归到最后的时刻。这并不是说一旦你满30岁，你就被定型了。这就是你余生要成为的人。不，你的大脑仍在继续发育，你的性格实际上在你的余生中确实会继续改变。但这只是其中一个时刻，你真的会看到活动的高峰或差异化。所以如果土星回归，你的土星回归让你觉得一切都在改变，
it's good to know that this is actually just a part of human development. I think it's very soothing to see it as something that, see it as a process that you have to go through. If all of this is sounding suspiciously like a quarter-life crisis or rock bottom, you are not wrong. The astrological definition is one thing. This does have another name, whether we call it Saturn return, whether we call it a quarter-life crisis. These are actually incredibly similar. And people have done studies where they have compared self-reporting and anecdotal reporting on these
很高兴知道这其实只是人类发展的一部分。我认为把它看作某种东西，看作一个你必须经历的过程，会非常抚慰人心。如果这一切听起来非常像四分之一人生危机或人生谷底，你并没有错。占星术的定义是一回事。这还有另一个名字，不管我们称之为土星回归，还是四分之一人生危机。这些其实非常相似。人们做过研究，他们把对这些经历的自我报告和轶事报告进行了对比，
experiences side by side, they're kind of explaining like the same thing. And applying a quarter life crisis perspective on our satin returns, I think gives us and gives, like allows us to have a more psychological take on it. This isn't just a pop psychology term. Again, this is a very real transition that if you got a thousand, 20 somethings in a room, you could literally map it. You could map it time and time again where these changes start to happen. Why tension in love, tension in careers, tension in family is going to push us to change who we are. Okay, what do we do about it? I feel like I've gone on long enough about like the things that you are going to experience or have experienced and perhaps why. And if you're feeling totally like lost and like
它们解释的其实是同一件事。将四分之一人生特有的危机视角应用到我们的土星回归上，我认为可以让我们——允许我们对其有更心理学化的理解。这不仅仅是一个流行心理学词汇。再说一次，这是一个非常真实的转变，如果你把一千个二十多岁的年轻人聚在一个房间里，你真的可以把它绘制出来。你可以一次又一次地绘制出这些变化开始发生的时间。为什么爱情中的紧张、职业中的紧张、家庭中的紧张会推动我们改变自己。好吧，我们对此该怎么办？我觉得我已经讲了足够长的时间，关于你将要经历或已经经历的事情以及原因。如果你完全感到迷茫，仿佛
life is beyond repair, what is the first step that you have to take to at least just feel a little bit less uncomfortable in this period? What can we do to help ourselves? Well, I'm going to give you some suggestions from not really my own experience, but from, yeah, my own experience with like rock bottom moments and hard moments, but also from people. people who have lived to tell the tale. This is a pilgrimage, right? This is an identity pilgrimage that millions, no, billions of people have gone through before you. So as isolating as it feels right now, research does show that people who actively wrestle with their identity development and with uncertainty in their 20s and who confront it head on, they actually emerge with
生活已经无法修复，你要采取的第一步是什么，才能在这个时期至少感觉稍微不那么难受一点？我们能做什么来帮助自己？嗯，我要给你一些建议，其实不是来自我自己的经验，而是来自，好吧，我自己在生活谷底和艰难时刻的经验，但也来自那些经历过这一切并活下来的人。这是一次朝圣，对吧？这是一次成百上千万人，不，数十亿人在你之前经历过的认同朝圣。所以尽管现在感觉如此孤立无援，但研究确实表明，那些在20多岁时积极与自己的认同发展和不确定性作斗争、并正面迎难而上的人，他们最终会带着
stronger self-knowledge. They emerge with greater resilience in their 30s compared to people who try and ignore it or push through in a life that they don't actually like. So not to sound like a toxic positivity guru, but going through this now and as intensely as you are is ultimately a good thing and is saving you from investing further in this life and then feeling like you're even more responsible for it and you'd have to sacrifice so much more to leave. Don't shoot me for saying that. I know that if you're going through it right now, like secretly, that's not something that you want to hear. But the application and finding meaning in it all actually is really helpful for the process. If we think back to that narrative identity research, again, we will find that the story we tell ourselves
更强的自我认知脱颖而出。与那些试图忽视它或在一个他们其实并不喜欢的生命中硬撑的人相比，他们在30岁时会表现出更强的韧性。所以听起来不像是那些贩卖虚假正能量的大师，但现在经历这一切，而且经历得如此强烈，归根结底是一件好事，它能让你免于进一步投入这段生活，进而觉得自己对它负有更多责任，而要想离开就得牺牲更多。别因为我这么说而朝我开枪。我知道如果你现在正经历这一切，暗地里，这绝对不是你想听的话。但应用它并在其中寻找意义，对这个过程其实真的很有帮助。如果我们回想一下那个关于叙事认同的研究，我们会发现，我们对自己讲述的故事——
about who we are and what we're going through and why our challenges are important actually makes a huge difference to how we approach them. And a lot of this does come down to reframing. It's easy to see endings, the ending of a relationship, a job, a friendship, a city that you lived in as a failure. But during this period, endings are often just realignments or maybe even protection. Whether you want to call it the planets, God, the universe, your brain, you need to give this period in your life a label. And you need to acknowledge why it may be necessary in order to have that meaning. that makes it feel like you couldn't have it any other way. You can't see it as defeat.
关于我们是谁、我们正在经历什么、为什么我们的挑战很重要——实际上对我们如何对待它们有着巨大的影响。而这很大程度上归结于重新构架。我们很容易把结局——一段关系的结束、一份工作的结束、一段友谊的结束、你曾居住过的一座城市的结束——视为失败。但在这一时期，结局往往只是重新调整，甚至可能是某种保护。不管你想把它称之为行星、上帝、宇宙还是你的大脑，你需要给生活中的这个时期贴上一个标签。而且你需要承认为什么它可能是必要的，以便赋予那种让你觉得别无选择的意义。你不能把它视为失败。
Anytime that you like have a negative connotation or a negative thought about this that feels unbearable and life-changing, you're allowed to feel crap day to day, but anytime you have a thought that's like, this is never going to get better, this is completely useless. My whole life is burning down for nothing. Again, the meaning making can frame the upheaval as part of your story. It's the chapter where you figure out who you are. It's the chapter where you figure out what matters to you, what life you actually want. That in itself will make all of this feel a lot more terrifying and more purposeful. I also want you to make a promise to yourself. I am going to work through this. I'm going to
每当你对这件事情产生负面含义或负面想法，觉得难以承受且改变人生时，你每天都可以感到沮丧，但每当你有一个诸如“这永远不会变好”、“这完全没用”、“我的整个人生都在化为灰烬，毫无意义”这样的想法时，意义建构可以把这种剧变框定为你故事的一部分。这是你弄清楚自己是谁的章节。这是你弄清楚什么对你重要、你到底想要什么生活的章节。仅此一点，就会让这一切感觉不那么可怕，而且更有目的性。我也希望你对自己做出一个承诺。我要熬过这一切。我要
give up some control for the first time in my life. I'm going to let myself float through these changes and let life take me where it wants me to go. I'm not going to find. I'm not going to find it, this is the promise I want you to make, I'm not going to fight it, I'm going to actually allow myself to be surprised. It's a very stoic idea, but you might not be able to make this chapter easier, you can just allow yourself to struggle a little bit less. Also, ask people about their own period of this in their lives. Ask your parents, ask your older friends, hear their stories. Everyone who I have asked has been like, I wouldn't be who I am today without what I went through during my satin return or during this period of the end of my 20s. I would go through it
生平第一次放弃一些控制权。我要让自己在这些变化中随波逐流，让生活带我去它想让我去的地方。我不会去抗争。我不会去抗争——这是我希望你做出的承诺——我不会去抗争，我实际上要允许自己感到惊讶。这是一个非常斯多葛派的想法，但你可能无法让这个章节变得更容易，你只是可以让自己稍微不那么艰难一点。另外，向别人询问他们生命中经历这一时期的故事。问问你的父母，问问你年长的朋友，听听他们的故事。我问过的每个人都说：“如果没有经历土星回归或20多岁末尾这段时期的经历，我就不会成为今天的我。”我愿意再经历它
again in a heartbeat. It has made me who I am. It's like people exchanging war stories. Like it's scary. It's also strangely comforting for people involved, right? There's this great article from The Cut titled Seven Saturn Survival Stories. I think it's behind a paywall. You should still get the free subscription or like the free seven day trial and read it because it is these stories from these incredible women who are on the other side that in the mid-30s, early 40s who are now have the hindsight to reflect and give us the wisdom on this period that you may really require. Some other advice that I have gotten is to just choose one thing to ground you and stay loyal to during this period. So when everything else is changing, find something that's stable.
一次，毫不犹豫。它造就了我。这就像人们在交流战争故事。虽然可怕，但对相关的人来说，也有一种奇怪的安慰，对吧？《The Cut》杂志上有一篇很棒的文章，题为《七个土星生存故事》。我想它是付费阅读的。你还是应该去弄个免费订阅或者七天免费试用阅读一下，因为这些故事来自于那些已经度过难关、处于30岁中期、40岁初期的非凡女性，她们现在拥有后见之明，可以对这一时期进行反思，并给出你可能非常需要的智慧。我得到的另一个建议是，在这个时期，只选择一件事来让你脚踏实地并对它保持忠诚。所以当其他一切都在改变时，找一些稳定的东西。
start training for a half marathon, start a reading challenge, commit to journaling every night, go sober, adopt a cat, foster a dog, focus on being a good family member, a good volunteer, a good community member, start a new project, just choose something that is within your control to center you, kind of like an anchor that is going to be something that you can come back to, this touch point, that you can always have agency around that's going to bring you a little bit of piece. Also write, record yourself, make a private video diary, capture this moment for yourself in the future to really take in all the lessons that you are learning right now. I did this when I went through my first adult big girl breakup. I still have the videos. It's painful to watch,
开始训练半程马拉松，开始一项阅读挑战，承诺每晚写日记，戒酒，领养一只猫，寄养一只狗，专注于做一个优秀的家庭成员、优秀的志愿者、优秀的社区成员，开始一个新的项目，只选择一些在你控制范围内的事情来让你集中精神，有点像一个锚，将成为你可以回过头来的东西，这个触点，你可以始终对它拥有自主权，它会给你带来一点平静。还要写作，录下你自己的视频，制作一个私密的视频日记，为未来的自己记录下这个时刻，真正领会你现在正在学习的所有教训。当我经历我第一次成年后的盛大分手时，我就是这么做的。我到现在还留着那些视频。看它会很痛苦，
but I suggest it to anyone and everyone who was going through something really hard. I recorded myself every single time. I felt down about the relationship or I felt like, crying or I was crying and I kept doing that until I didn't want to until I didn't need to anymore and documenting that pain and these changes it makes it feel like it's important and it means something. You don't share it with anyone. Like I've never shared that video. Well, I think there's like 50 videos to be honest. Like I've never shared those. It's kind of just for me. And when I go back and I watch it like the final video is was me, I think. I can't remember whether it was like a year or two. years later, but it was a really heartwarming. It was just this video of me being like,
但我向任何和所有正在经历真正艰难时期的人推荐这样做。每当我对这段感情感到沮丧，或者觉得想哭，或者正在哭的时候，我都把自己的样子录下来，我一直这样做，直到我不想这样做为止，直到我不再需要这样做为止。记录下这种痛苦和这些变化，会让它感觉很重要，并且有某种意义。你不需要跟任何人分享。就像我从来没有分享过那个视频。好吧，老实说，大概有50个视频吧。我从来没有分享过那些。它其实只是给我自己的。当我回去看它时，最后一个视频是我，我想。我不记得是一年后还是两
it's going to be okay. And it was okay. And kind of laughing in a nice way. I like this previous version of me who was so deep in despair, like she did not see it getting any better. And here I was like telling her that it did. And I think that having that for yourself is truly powerful. and having the vision of a future you being able to look back in hindsight and celebrate this period is a lot of comfort in itself. I'm sending you guys a lot of love. I think you just need to have patience. You just need to have patience that this is part of the long, messy work of being human
年后的事了，但那真的很暖心。那只是我的一段视频，在说：一切都会好起来的。而且确实好了。并且带着一种美好的方式在笑。我喜欢这个曾经陷入绝望深渊的过去的自己——她根本看不到事情会变好的迹象。而我却在这里告诉她，事情确实变好了。我认为为自己保留这样一个视频真的很有力量。拥有未来自己的愿景，能够带着后见之明回首过去并庆祝这段时期，本身就是一种极大的安慰。我向大家发送许多爱。我想你只需要有耐心。你只需要有耐心，相信这是做人过程中漫长而凌乱的工作的一部分，
and of being in your 20s. And your 20s, you know, they just want to go out with a bang. Like they've taught you so much. They continue to teach you so much. They want to get all the lessons in before you enter this new chapter. So leave space for that. Leave space to just like learn and process and grieve and share, share what you are going through with other people. Sometimes like the best remedy is someone else just being like, yeah, me too.
也是处于20多岁这一年纪的一部分。你知道，20多岁的人，他们只是想轰轰烈烈地结束。就像他们教给你那么多东西一样。他们继续教给你那么多东西。他们想在你进入这个新篇章之前学完所有的课程。所以给这个过程留出空间。留出空间去学习、去处理、去悲伤、去分享，与其他人分享你正在经历的事情。有时候最好的解药就是另一个人说：“是的，我也是。”
And not feeling alone. So again, good luck. I'm actually deeply excited for you. Obviously I'm not going through it with you. I'm sure if I was in your shoes, I would not want to hear someone saying that. So I'm sorry, but I am deeply excited for you. I just think so much amazing stuff is going to come out of this that you don't even know yet. How cool is that?
并且不再感到孤单。所以再次祝你好运。实际上我为你感到深深的兴奋。显然我没有和你一起经历。我敢肯定，如果我站在你的鞋子里，我不会想听到别人这么说。所以对不起，但我真的为你感到兴奋。我只是觉得这其中会产生如此多你现在还不知道的精彩事物。这不是很酷吗？
If you enjoyed this episode, make sure to leave a comment down below. Tell me when your sat in return began. Was it a little bit earlier? Are you still going through it? What are you learning during this period? Let's share some of those stories below so that hopefully, people can scroll through them and be like, oh my God, I feel so much less alone. I want to thank our research assistant Libby Colbert, as always for her help on this episode. She has taught me
如果你喜欢这一集，请务必在下方留个评论。告诉我你的土星回归是什么时候开始的。是不是稍微早一点？你还在经历吗？在这段时期你学到了什么？让我们在下方分享其中一些故事，希望人们可以滚动浏览它们，然后说：“天哪，我感觉没那么孤单了。”我要像往常一样感谢我们的研究助理莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）对这一集提供的帮助。她教给了我
so much about astrology as we kind of put together, yeah, this topic. So I appreciate her so much for all of her assistants. Make sure that you are following us over on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast to see behind the scenes. We also have December guest month coming up. at the end of the year. So if you want to see who is going to be on the show, who you're going to hear from, well, you better follow along. Our transcripts are as well now available on Substack and this episode is actually on YouTube. You've kind of already finished it if you're listening to this. So you might not want to go and rewatch it. But if you want to watch future episodes of the show, you should follow us over there, the psychology of your 20s on YouTube. But until next time,
关于占星术的那么多知识，当我们把这个主题拼凑在一起时。所以我非常感谢她所有的协助。请确保你在Instagram上关注我们：@That Psychology Podcast，以了解幕后花絮。我们在年底还会有12月嘉宾月。所以如果你想看看谁会出现在节目中，你想听到谁的声音，那么你最好关注我们。我们的文字稿现在也可以在Substack上找到了，这一集实际上也在YouTube上。如果你正在听这个，你其实已经听完了。所以你可能不想再去重看一遍。但如果你想观看该节目的未来剧集，你应该去YouTube上关注我们：the psychology of your 20s。但直到下一次，
Stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. Good luck with your sat and return. And we will talk very, very soon. Two percent. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。祝你的土星回归好运。我们很快就会再聊。百分之二。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上有炎症性。我们搞错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即I-Hart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方上的TWO percent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小肯姆（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克（Sam Jek）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集有马特·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）作嘉宾，
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
大谈80年代的快克毒品。澄清一下，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以谈论快克，只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这其中有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆上桌面了。谢谢你把话说完。是的。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games.
我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《用艰难的方式学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。
And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
为了纪念心理健康意识月，我将带上我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们仍在追逐，我们不知道什么时候才算够，因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于赢输的游戏。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗丝（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast. Learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
加入我，基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games），在我的新播客《用艰难的方式学习》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Eckerd）
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中惊人的矛盾之处。这开启了长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱之陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。嘿，大家好！你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）主持的《用艰难的方式学习》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在任何地方都不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。百分之二。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strength. modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with him. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that
我剖析了坚强的意志、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方上的TWO percent。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me.
相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
我是萨姆·杰（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马特·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是由人类制作的。本期节目还没有评论。点击文字稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。